[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with Joker
bringing smiles and laughter to a world
that's cruel and dark I thought I'd give
my thoughts on the events of the film
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down my fan theory that all of the movie
was in Arthur's head and the evidence to
support it I've seen the film twice now
and the second time the pointers were so
glaring that I don't know how I missed
it first watch now we're going to be
going over I love the movie so obviously
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch it yet
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now this is your last chance to back
out but if you're still here I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into a
breakdown of Joker
okay so Joker tells the story of Arthur
Fleck and nobody in the city of Gotham
that rises to the top and causes a riot
that sees the death of the Wayne's Joker
in the film is an unreliable narrator
that often hallucinates
and imagines things that simply don't
happen but what if the majority of the
events in the film didn't actually
happen at all and pretty much everything
was in the characters head well
personally I believe that the film is
actually about an insane inmate at
arkham asylum that stopped taking his
medication and created a fantasy in his
head that he started an uprising that
led to the deaths of the city's most
affluent family he kills a psychiatrist
at the end and there's a mad dash
throughout the halls of the complex
before he's caught and escorted back to
his cell now the reason that he hates
the Wayne's and wants to take
responsibility for their deaths is
because when he was growing up his
mother made him hate the family most
notably Thomas who she said mistreated
her when she worked at the manor none of
the events in the movie bother few
flashes that we see of the asylum are
real and this is simply Arthur imagining
that he's an important figure in Gotham
that brung down the person he hates more
than anything in the world
now else I can see a lot of people
instantly disagreeing with this and they
don't really blame you just yet but
there's actually a lot of evidence to
support this firstly
let's jump to the ending of the film
when we see Arthur being questioned by
his psychiatrist she asks him what
what's so funny and he begins laughing
Arthur simply can't contain himself and
we cut to his scene showing Bruce
standing over the bodies of his dead
parents which shows that he finds it
funny that they died Arthur then
continues laughing and says that you
won't get the joke and this is true
because the psychiatrist probably won't
know about his dislike for the Wayans
and even if she did she wouldn't
understand why he would take so much
Glee in their death this seems like the
first real genuine laugh from Arthur in
the film who up until this point has
been only laughing due to his condition
but what if during the entire events of
the film he was actually always in the
asylum well firstly the big pointer of
this to me comes early on in the movie
when Arthur is being questioned by his
psychiatrist she asks about his past at
the asylum and we cutted the characters
smacking his head against the door to
his cell before going back to his
therapy session personally I don't think
that this is a flashback at all and that
Arthur at this point is actually in the
asylum imagining that he's a free man
and the mere question of Arkham makes
him flash out of his delusion for a
brief second in which he has to hit his
head once more in order to reenter it we
see more evidence of this later in the
movie when Arthur is again speaking to
his psychiatrist but seemingly the final
time and he states that he feels like he
never really existed if the last point
is true then this interview is once
again at the asylum and Arthur is
admitting that the person he imagines in
his head doesn't really exist and then
it's all just make-believe
later in the film and Arthur is trying
to discover whether Thomas is his father
he grabs a file from a clerk played by
Brian Tyree Henry and Sprint's off down
the hall before stopping in a staircase
to read it but why did no one chase him
and how was he able to exit the building
so easily without being stalked surely
the gods would be on high alert knowing
that he's trying to leave with a
confidential document yeah we never see
this to me this is because he never
actually left the asylum and instead
stole the file read it in the staircase
and then was escorted back to his cell
Arthur also definitely didn't even meet
Thomas Wayne in the movie as we see when
he's punched in the bathroom that he
stands over the sink and we
to him in his apartment in the exact
same position which I think is a clear
indicator that he was never at the
theater what if he was never in his
apartment either well we do see him
climb into his bridge and then the next
scene he's in his bed with a phone
ringing all of these I think happened in
his cell and he's simply imagining the
circumstances are different to add
deeper to his fantasy Arthur admits in
the film that he stopped taking his
pills and it could be that he was
prescribed medication in the asylum he
stopped taking them by either hiding or
flushing them and this allows his
fantasy to build but disregarding that
the biggest and final pointer to me is
the way that the finale is edited in the
final few moments of the movie we see
Arthur's standing on top of a cop car
being cheered in the middle of the riot
that has brought the city to its knees
we instantly flashed to Arthur being
questioned almost as if he's once again
being snapped out of it and for a brief
second he flashes back to the fantasy to
see Bruce standing over their bodies
Arthur at this point is completely
involved in the fantasy due to no longer
taking his pills and he snaps and kills
his psychiatrist after realizing that
none of the fantasy was real before
being chased through the halls of the
asylum like scooby-doo I really think
when watching the film under the context
that this is an insane inmate who is
being interviewed snapping in and out of
his fantasy that the film holds a lot of
weight and actually makes more sense and
Arthur simply being delusional some of
the time now who knows I might watch the
film again and think that I'm completely
wrong but there are definitely some
pointers at the very least that show
that this might all be in his head now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on my theory and if you agree with me or
have your own did this video even happen
are you even watching it what is YouTube
I don't know make sure you comment below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video then please like it and go and
check out my breakdown and review of
Joker which would be linked at the end I
got all over the film on a more surface
level and give my thoughts on it and the
controversy surrounding it so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
enjoyed this video you want to come chat
to me on Twitter that make sure you
follow me at the username on the screen
and if you want to join my discord then
make sure you click on the link in the
description below we've got an awesome
community and it's the best way to stay
up to date with
channel also just wanna let you know
that we're currently giving away a free
copy of spider-man far from home on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with the chance of winning is to like
this video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on Joker in the comment section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blue arrow be
shipped out from then Tuba gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you